[Music]
all right and welcome to Hannity and as
we begin tonight we have breaking news a
former high-ranking FBI special agent
his name is Charles mcgonical now he
just pled guilty to violations and U.S
sanctions and laundering payments from a
Russian oligarch well here's the
important part uh to note and that is
Charles wasn't just any Rank and file
member of the FBI knew senior agent had
a prominent role in forming ironically
operation Crossfire hurricane and
perpetuating the Russia hoax and the
hoax that John Durham said he that never
should have existed let me put it simply
the guy that was out there accusing
president Trump of colluding with Russia
he was the one that was actually
colluding with Russia don't worry he
will be the next hero guest on msdnc and
fake news CNN but mcgonaco well he
wasn't alone and we begin tonight with
this a simple truth and a sad reality
the United States of America today does
not have equal justice under the law it
does not have equal application of our
laws we have a dual justice system we do
have a doj that has been politicized and
it has been weaponized in ways this
country has never seen before some
examples let's look at Hillary Clinton
and her 2016 campaign you know paying an
ex-foreign spy Christopher Steele a ton
of money to put together campaign op
research that was filled with Russian
disinformation against then candidate
Donald J Trump adopt research known as
the Hillary Clinton Clinton dirty
Russian dossier that was formed out to
every media Outlet government
institution in America as quote real
intelligence all in a phony effort to
First shape the 20 election
results and then afterwards when they
lost then to use those to question the
results after Donald Trump won in
America today if you are a prominent
Democrat right last name's Clinton or
Biden it's totally okay to deny election
results you can even use Russian
disinformation to do it no problem at
all but if your last name is Trump if
you're a republican a conservative
you'll be indicted for jaywalking likely
facing 10 years in jail late last night
more charges for Donald Trump and 18
quote co-conspiratives out of Atlanta
for challenging the results of the 2020
election now with these additional 13
charges well Donald Trump faces a
whopping 712 years six months in prison
more than yeah the most convicted
killers on the streets that we don't
even arrest or if we do arrest them we
let them back out in minutes anyway it's
not just enough to beat Donald Trump
politically not in today's America not
in Joe Biden's America not with Joe
Biden's doj no today's Democrats in
Biden's weaponized justice system they
now want Biden's chief political rival
to be dead to die in prison for
challenging an election or having views
they don't agree with and right on cue
and lacking any and all self-awareness
and you really can't make this up one of
America's most prominent 2016 election
deniers the person that bought and paid
for the dirty Russian dossier Hillary
Clinton herself heads on over it's a
very friendly territory over at msdnc
why to celebrate Donald Trump's
indictment and scold any and all
Americans who dare to question the
legitimacy of an election and by the way
you're about to see hypocrisy and
dishonesty in a way that's almost
surreal it's poetic take a look
so this attack on the elections was the
most important step in a long line of
efforts undertaken to undermine our
trust and our belief in a functioning
democracy and our commitment to one
person one vote you can run the best
campaign
you can even become the nominee
and you can have the election stolen
from you one of the things that we have
learned by living it in these past few
years is that
democracy needs the trust of the people
that's right that um the system of
democracy at its heart is the idea that
the people get to decide how we are
governed Russia Russian government
Russian military Russian intelligence
interfered in the U.S presidential
election in 2016 to try to help Donald
Trump win that election but I don't know
that anybody should be satisfied this
this is a terrible moment for our
country to have uh a former president
accused of these uh terribly uh
important crimes I believe he knows he's
an illegitimate president if Bad actors
tell us falsely that every election is
stolen and that the only way an election
is trustworthy is if they come out on
top of it
um then something it's it tells you
something not just about that person or
that moment it maybe wounds us as a
democracy and in a way that is hard to
repair Russia was interfering in the
election
um and they weren't doing it on their
own and he was in on it you know the
truth matters
all right so Hillary Clinton she's the
one that was saying the election was
illegitimate when she lost she paid for
the Russian dirty dossier and you know
Outlets like MSD and c and and fake news
CNN and the New York Times Washington
Post they peddled those lies in
conspiracy theories for years and they
were dead wrong truth matters not to
Hillary not to the media mob none of
them they tried to discredit an election
by spreading lies and conspiracy
theories about Donald Trump and Russia
they're still pushing them six years
seven years later the Durham probe found
the crossfire hurricane was never ever
Justified Russia did not hack the 2016
election Donald Trump was not an
illegitimate president there wasn't a
single thing that he found in the in the
Russian disinformation dossier Hillary
paid for that was true and she and her
allies never faced any consequences for
spreading actual Russian disinformation
that they paid for Hillary also never
faced any legal consequences for
mishandling top secret classified
material stored on her unsecured private
servers that many uh enemy countries
were able to hack into like China her
office her home never raided neither was
Joe Biden's they had top secret
classified information everywhere she
never faced charges for obstructing
justice after deleting 33 000 subpoenaed
emails wiping servers hard drives clean
with bleach bitten smashing phones and
and blackberries with hammers she also
never faced any consequences from the
uranium one Scandal remember that was
the Scandal that resulted in Russia one
of our biggest geopolitical foes getting
20 percent of our uranium critical to
the enrichment of our nuclear weapons
and we don't have enough of it Hillary
also never faced consequences for
Benghazi although sketchy foreign
business payments to the Clinton
foundation so I go back to my point if
you are a prominent Democrat you can
pretty much do whatever you want you
will get away with it another example
the family of a certain Democratic
senator turned vice president and raking
in tens of millions of dollars in cash
from corrupt countries our top
geopolitical foes and is often the case
around the globe Russia China Romania
Kazakhstan Ukraine this family Syndicate
led by Hunter Biden at the time a drug
addict had absolutely no experience at
all with these countries or in the case
of Ukraine and China in the energy
sphere but he's getting paid a fortune
millions and millions of dollars thanks
to Pops they had but one thing to sell
and that was the Biden brand the Joe
Biden brand access to a prominent
Senator turned vice president now your
President Joe Biden they set up phone
calls they had me meetings they had
dinners at the beautiful Cafe Milano
with the big guy and even reportedly got
Pops to alter U.S policy for a price at
least one trusted Source accused Joe
Biden and his son of accepting a
multi-million dollar bribe and tonight a
mountain of other evidence suggesting
Joe got paid in a multitude of other
ways a former Biden business partner
told the New York Post that multiple
Biden family members they paid for
pretty much all of Joe's living expenses
quote it's vacations it's cell phones
it's money to pay taxes this is Joe
Biden's brothers sisters children
grandchildren taking care of him they
were the ones being paid a fortune
cashing in on Joe Biden's name and
position and according to a 2018 tax
from Hunter Biden he paid for Dad's
bills for more than a decade including
credit card charges from Hunter's Wells
Fargo Wells Fargo account so I was
Hunter paying pop spills why were
members of his family nine members
according to Jay James Comer why were
they getting all these all this money
from all these foreign countries what
did what did Hunter Biden what did the
grandchildren do to receive these
massive sums of money all the while
Hunter was quote neglecting well to pay
taxes on millions of dollars in income
it's almost as if they were operating as
one illicit organization with the big
guy at the top and then of course he had
his friends slow walk in the
investigation letting the statute of
limitations run out how great a gig is
this this is typically what you see in a
real Rico a racketeering case but
President Biden he's not been charged
with any crimes welcome to Joe Biden's
America in fact as far as we know he's
not even under investigation instead
it's former president Trump 18 others
including his own lawyers no
attorney-client privilege that has been
waived that's uh we will get rid of that
we'll use the crime fraud exception uh
charged with racketeering they're not
accused of accepting Farm bribes in
exchange for policy decision like that
1023 form says like Joe Biden you know
they're not accused of paying an
ex-foreign spy to spread Russian
disinformation to interfere with an
election like Hillary Clinton instead
they're accused of challenging election
results something Democrats have been
doing since Al Gore tried to reverse the
2000 election in Florida by finding
votes with only selective recounts only
in Democratic districts that's what they
tried for left-wing prosecutors charging
Donald Trump it isn't about the truth
it's not about democracy it's about
power it's about vengeance and it's
about blocking Donald Trump from ever
going before the voters to even become
president give them the option of him
becoming president again Democrats have
now bludgeoned our justice system using
it as a political weapon against
Republicans and a political shield from
their for their fellow Democrats it's
now more obvious than ever and it's
probably why Hunter and his lawyers
think they believe they can reinstate
this sweetheart plea deal make no
mistake America's unequal abusively
biased justice system is now ripping
this country to shreds coming up an
early victim of Jack Smith and the
weaponized system of justice that's
former Virginia governor Bob McDonald
where do you hear his story hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else